depuis son retour dans l'archipel de son
enfance il n'a qu'une seule idée en tête
alerter les populations locales sur la
fragilité de la nature et renouer avec
son identité grâce à l'océan et des
kilomètres de nage entre les îles
polynésiennes
aujourd'hui un grand défi attend ismaël
retrouver son archipel de naissance les
îles marquises et les relier entre elles
par une hache symbolique de plusieurs
dizaines de kilomètres
ce chapelet d'îles volcaniques posé au
milieu du pacifique est à 1500 km au
nord-est de tahiti
[Musique]
où
ismaël arrive à bord dollar à nouilles
un cargo mixte qui ravitaille deux fois
par mois les îles principales de
l'archipel
un lien vital pour les quelques 10000
habitants de ces terres isolées
ismaël débarque accompagné d'hervé son
ami d'enfance qui va le suivre dans la
réalisation de son défi
[Musique]
l'île de houat peau c'est le point de
départ de leur aventure
en arrivant il faut suivre la coutume et
se rendre chez le responsable
communautaire de lille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tv callas et le maire de woippy un homme
incontournable
avec son projet de relier les îles à la
nage
ismaël participe à l'affirmation d'une
culture marquisienne à part entière
[Musique]
ici les défunts reviennent réincarné en
éléments de la nature il s'exprime à
travers le vent le comportement des
animaux et bien sur l'océan nager dans
l'océan comme tu le fais je le considère
un peu comme
toi étant dans le placenta de ta main
armée tàu terrethique ouailles à kaolack
est la mettrais pas sûrs et a
annoncé
au nom et aux tirs au but
je me regarde pas
quel est le lien non pas simplement
culturel mais le lien
spirituel
des îles marquises avec lui
à nous
[Musique]
ghana
cocoa is my boy a mac vous êtes les
messages il
le plus extraordinaire
à nous devons montrer l'exemple
et à vous d'essayer d'amener cet exemple
là où vous pouvez et ce mal et pas au
ras oui oui à
aurélie côté
[Musique]
caron
et
il va leur montrer l'exemple
avec cette nage
c'est le départ vers la première ville à
60 km en direction du nord
sous l'eau ismaël est attentif aux mânes
à cette énergie vitale mystique qui
relie les polynésiens à la nature
[Musique]
créature de l'océan parmi d'autres il
évolue d'une manière discrète en évitant
tout geste brusque qui pourrait sembler
agressif je mets ma main droite au fond
sont en train de monter mon énergie
de le montrer ma présence de la tille je
suis là
[Musique]
et de le recevoir après l'énergie de
lotion
[Musique]
c'est une nage symbolique ponctuée par
des sessions de repos à bord d'un
catamaran
une base vie qui lui permet également de
se mettre à l'eau quand ils le désirent
à bord pablo un marin dow à pau a
rejoint l'équipe
il
aux marquises l'océan n'a rien de
pacifique
les courants les vents lève des houles
impressionnante
mais ismaël a appris à ne plus avoir
peur
il est en confiance avec l'océan
[Musique]
le franchissement des roches et des
sentinelles marque enfin l'arrivée sur
l'île de nuku hiva
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
wae
peut-être l'étape la plus émouvante pour
ismaël
c'est son île d'origine la terre qui l'a
vu grandir
[Musique]
après 20 ans d'exil c'est un retour aux
sources sur la terre des hommes comme
les marquisiens appellent leur archipel
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
quant au bout et au miam miam à
tottenham
et l'inter mais le pauvre femme à
pretoria marbre
avant on a appris que vous avez un an
non
retour sur la terre des hommes pour
ismaël cette escale est aussi l'occasion
de rencontrer les habitants qui incarne
au mieux cette relation à la nature et à
la culture de l'île
il va visiter les sites anciens de la
vallée qui retrouve aujourd'hui le
chemin de la lumière grâce au travail de
toute la communauté et des archéologues
roy puccini a contribué à remettre ses
sites en valeur
il accompagne ismaël et hervé vers le
rocher de la tortue unique par le nombre
de petroglyph marin qui l'arborent
[Musique]
mon crâne et coup à wau
nantais mère au foyer
à taux zéro
g 8 mois
mais a tenu
tout cas nous nous y sommes
bayod des familles toyer payot
[Musique]
avez vous été plutôt pauvre n'a été ni
intérim et où la nec avio tel
trou et maman la cavayère coûte mike
whan
le voyage continue au rythme du vent et
de la houle
guide et parfois par de joyeux
compagnons
[Musique]
bon
après 65 km à la nage et à la voile il
arrive en vue de la troisième île
visiter ou en tout cas
[Musique]
ici la gestion des îlots aux oiseaux
rappelle à ismaël cet art de vivre
millénaire et respectueux de la nature
tandis que sur un daisy lowe les oiseaux
s'ébattent à l'abri de toute pression
humaine
sur l'autre la tradition de collecte des
oeufs se poursuit d'une manière
raisonnée
au sud de wau cas dans la baie d'année
les jeunes de l'île réinventent leur
relation avec l'océan
accompagné par vanessa tpa ils ont la
responsabilité d'une aire marine
éducative un concept né aux marquises et
qui depuis a essaimé partout en
outre-mer et en métropole l'objectif est
d'échanger avec tous ceux qui sont en
lien avec le milieu marin au sein de la
communauté des îles
ce matin ismaël a rendez vous avec eux
sur la plage
[Musique]
l'idée ce que vous puissiez montrer
expliquer comment nous on travaille il
va vous poser des questions à vous de
les ré pondre ça marche chercher est ce
que vous faites en premier on faisait de
la
[Applaudissements]
plongée et après
[Musique]
l'important normalement c'est pas ou de
la masse et vous avez trois de dire aux
adultes
stop c'est pas à nous à ramasser vos
déchets c'est à vous à nous donner
l'exemple c'est ça que vous devez dire
aux adultes
la belle ana
[Musique]
le comptable amen
si on a confiance en soi on peut le
faire merci on n'a pas confiance en soi
on pourra pas le faire parce qu'ils ya
le doute
il faut pas planche encore en fait pas
de me trouver
l'être humain quand il est dans l'océan
il est patent que
beaucoup d'imagés vient de frapper aux
yeux
[Musique]
les images de la peur est tout
simplement de l'imagination de l'être
humain
à l'organiste pas
au savon des images du peu
après tant d'années temps de parcours je
connais même plus cette image là
[Musique]
oh misère des neiges ici de parler à
tous les animaux
d'être en connexion avec eux de savoir à
quelle distance il s'en est ce qui me
suit
est-ce qu'ils sont deux ronds
[Musique]
je me sens humain reçu dans l'océan
le cas marteau à chaque fois que je fais
quelque chose il vient pour valider ou
dire que talents d'aujourd'hui elle a
accepté elle est validée
[Musique]
lille d'hiva oa est la quatrième étape
de cette odyssée
[Musique]
hiva oa est une île riche en vestiges
archéologiques
la végétation dense de la vallée de
poids mao abrite le tawahi paul où se
dressent les plus grands tiki des
marquises
ou moucaye mouko guide ismaël et hervé
dans ce site sacré
[Musique]
ces statues garde temps elle le mana
l'énergie vitale des guerriers des chefs
qu'elle représente
photo dr quinine et tao totino
lots
non kawaï
et un autre mois
dans la cohue
à carreaux mais pas ou tout d'abord
animal noir à garou homme est parti
mais où que my
nîmois nos rives du doubs a eu lui carol
packard ou hama et a pour tous les goûts
yahoo tacaille ali
hiva oa est à watts à son des îles
soeurs séparées l'une de l'autre de
quelques kilomètres à peine
elle se situe dans la partie sud de
l'archipel des marquises
c'est la dernière étape du voyage
d'ismael sur la trace de ses ancêtres
par son approche de l'océan il a tissé
un lien spirituel entre chacune des îles
[Musique]
avec ses compagnons de nage il s'offre
une dernière fois aux bleus des
profondeurs
avant de débarquer sur l'île de tahoua
tas en pl matin le festival culturel des
marquises où se retrouvent les meilleurs
tatoueur de l'archipel
[Musique]
le tatouage marquisien longtemps
interdite est oublié c'est aujourd'hui
répandue dans le monde entier
alors que l'origine et le sens des
symboles avait presque disparu
les marquisiens se sont réappropriés cet
art ancestral et douloureux
[Musique]
les poitevins de vendredi dont les poils
tous les motifs que j'ai je plaisante un
peu
la carte de mal puisqu'il
à chaque tige que j'allais où je me fais
tatouer
j'ai beaucoup de tatouages marc
le de l'océan
c'est une tension
est une
lettre
décrit fort qu'on est dans l'eau sans
elles nous observe
[Musique]
longtemps délaissé la culture
marquisienne rené aujourd'hui au coeur
d'un monde occidental en quête de sens
l'odyssey d'ismaël fait de légende de
rêve et d'intuition nous rappelle à quel
point la nature et puissante vivante est
nécessaire à notre survie
[Musique]